all right kevin so how can i help you
man um so one of the things i wanted to
ask about
was um my mom and my grandma keep
sharing political videos and articles
often dozens of times a day and most of
it looks like propaganda to me
um without telling them i actually
unfollowed both of them on social media
just because they were stressing me out
with all the stuff they were putting
forward
and then they started just directly
messaging me
like all these things all these videos
about like it's going to be the end of
america if x gets elected
or y is trying to rig the election this
side or the other
and i talked to my mom and said hey um
this stuff stresses me out could you
please stop
sending it to me and she responded well
i just want you to know what to pray for
and i feel like both she and my grandma
are using the excuse of prayer to
kind of fall down a political rabbit
hole so
would you say it's disrespectful for me
to just ignore the messages which is
kind of what i'm doing right now or
should i try to convince them
that what they're doing is unhealthy man
that's a lot there so i'm going to run
through this relatively quick are you
ready kevin
yes number one you named one of my pet
peeves brother
which is people who use prayer
who use mindfulness who use this this
shroud of love and care
to spread gossip about people
right we've seen these people at church
are like i don't want to gossip but you
know what susie's been up to right
um we need to pray for billy because
he's about to go to jail right it's just
a way to
to snake your way into a conversation
that really at the root of it is about
disparaging people i can't stand that
right
um so number two dude um
you've done the noble thing which is to
have the conversation
my recommendation is to have it one more
time and
maybe even via email so they can have it
in writing and they can go back to it
and here's why
when somebody's amygdala is engaged when
the stress center or
fear center of their brain is on fire
they cannot be reasoned with right and
our brains
work that way on purpose they don't want
us looking at the entrance of a cave and
being like
is that a nice bear or a gentle bear
maybe that's a mean bear
our brains just are designed to say run
dude there's a bear we'll figure out if
he's nice
later we're out and so when we have
people in our lives
and we all do brother kevin who are
convinced that this is the end of time
this is it we things are up that if
president a is elected we're all going
to be okay if president b is elected
it's we're all gonna die we are gonna
die and there are hurricanes in the gulf
two of them just landed at the same time
the west coast is on fire
fill in the blank it's all a struggle
right now
when we have folks in our life like that
just sitting down and trying to talk
facts and sense is not helpful it's just
not
and so yes at some point after you draw
that boundary and say
i'm asking you all to stop i'm going to
continue to pray for our country i'm
going to
pray for our family i'm going to pray
for everybody i don't need the details
anymore
if they do it after that then yes you
got to ignore it you got to cut them off
you got to block them
you can tell your mom i'm going to call
you but i've asked you to stop sending
me this stuff and you continue to do it
and i know it's a hard conversation to
have but it is a bold adult
conversation and my promise is she loves
you
more than the drama and i think she'll
come around kevin um you sound like a
wise young man why is beyond many
of our of the folks i run with um who
just let our parents bombard us with
some of this stuff in our and our kids
and our friends and co-workers
but yeah draw boundaries and then if
people violate those boundaries
you have every right every every
responsibility to yourself and those who
love you to say i'm i'm out i'm not
going to respond to this nonsense i'm
going to block your phone call i'll call
you if i need something
for sure black people on social media
and whatnot but i think the the proper
way to do this is to write an email to
your mom
and your grandma and say i am praying
for our country i love things
this type of information i'm not
interested anymore i don't want to see
it anymore
please do not send it to me anymore and
kevin i've had those conversations in my
life and the folks that
know me and love me have respected those
boundaries and so um
man i appreciate the call i know that so
many people across the country
millions are dealing with this exact
thing
and here's the deal at the end of this
election regardless of who's elected
and who ends up in washington who's not
whatever
i'm still gonna have to go to starbucks
and see the waitress
see the person at the counter i'm still
gonna pump gas next to you
in your car i'm still gonna see you at
the grocery store
i'm still going to email back and forth
to you at work
at the end of the day our relationships
with one another is all that matters
washington has never
my problems are not going to be solved
in washington good folks my problems are
going to be solved locally
in my neighborhood in my office in my
heart
i believe that strongly and i want to
encourage everybody to begin to
open back up your relationships around
you with your loved ones and respect
each other's boundaries